I saw black panther and if I looked
stoned out of my mind just because I'm
dead as tired three hours of sleep those
morning screenings in Seattle they kill
me black panther so Black Panther is the
newest installment in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe directed by Ryan
Coogler when I look at his body of work
and his age he's younger than me I look
at him and I'm like I've done so little
different Black Panther starts out
shortly after Captain America's Civil
War two challahs father was killed in
Civil War he is now gonna be crowned
king but he's also the Black Panther so
in that there's that balance he has to
balance being King and dealing with the
problems that come with that but also
being the Black Panther and problems
that come with that I don't envy his
position I really don't and when this
movie doesn't right it does it right
when you look at Chadwick Boseman and
the performance he gives also Michael B
Jordan the performance he gives both of
them have very emotional moments in this
movie when you really think about it
they're on a green screen they're not
out there actually it's a green screen
what kind of imagination do you have to
have to pull that kind of performance
when you're looking at a sea of green
when you look at what these movies are
doing as they're shifting into deeper
character pieces quiet breath sometimes
you can tell the green screen which is a
bummer a couple scenes where they're
talking I'm like that that's a green
screen you couldn't find a mountain you
couldn't just talk on a mountain I don't
know I don't make movies maybe they
couldn't maybe it's just too cumbersome
to bring it crew up there but I liked
the arc they gave King T'Challa because
when we saw him in Captain America Civil
War he ultimately was a dude on a
revenge quest and I totally get to class
me that hard all the time I want to see
the guy's heart how is he as a king is
he just like yeah well they did a bad
thing I guess we'll kill him too no he's
not like that at all it totally shows
the guy's heart he is a good King and as
his father tells him it's hard to be a
good man and a good king and you totally
feel that as Captain America was the
introduction to him this is the movie
that gives that arc more relevant this
is one of those movies that strips away
the armor we see the King behind the
black panther the man behind the armor I
love stories like that unpopular opinion
coming at you I really enjoyed Iron Man
3 and I really loved the first Thor
because both of those movies strip away
the hero and we deal with the person
behind the hero this movie does a lot of
that too yeah he does suit up in the
black panther suit and when he does is
pretty entertaining actually there's one
car chase sequence it's more than pretty
entertaining it's pretty kick-ass
well really when I think about this
movie I'm not gonna think about the
Black Panther scenes first and foremost
I'm going to think about the character
moments I'm gonna think about the
politics I'm gonna think about the
culture
I was so fascinated as to how into
wakandan culture I was it was so
fantastic you feel like you have a
front-row seat to all of it you're
interested and also how much of it stuck
with me I mean you really look at other
worlds and movies and comic book movies
they don't do the same thing this movie
as I can seem recent memory did it best
you see what a movie introduces the
audience to a new civilization or
culture when the audience leaves that
movie they can ask themselves what do I
know about that civilization or culture
and usually the answer is very little
it's not so the case with Wakanda with
Wakanda you walk out a black panther you
feel like you got a crash course in
Wakanda and when you see it it comes
across as a very beautiful and
celebratory thing I think that's
fantastic and reviewing an MCU movie you
got to address the Marvel isms which are
how does it tie into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as a whole does the
tie-in take point over the standalone
aspect of the movie and how is the humor
not is the humor in it but it's going to
be in it so how is it for a large chunk
of this movie it works as a standalone
film there are tie-ins in it the fact
that clause in it vibranium is a big
part of it also Martin Freeman's
character but if you just went into
Black Panther you would get the gist you
wouldn't need to watch another movie
maybe Civil War it being the first movie
with Black Panther but really nothing
else and I felt the humor really worked
what I look for with humor in a movie
like this or a Marvel movie is it's
going to have humor so does the humor
override the drama like if someone's
having a dramatic moment if there is a
moment that's supposed to marinate and
have drama if you're supposed to take a
pause is there a joke that compromises
the whole thing when that happens in
movies it irritates me this movie
doesn't do that the supporting cast and
characters that were fantastic - I love
those warrior ladies I loved his tech
head sister Lupita Nyong'o was fantastic
I loved him back ooh he's the character
man ape but they never call him man
Abby's calling Tanaka I believe it is
pronounced mbaku I'm horrible with names
names like Smith I'm like was it Smith
or Smyth but he was great I wanted to
see more of him he was so good and I had
heard fantastic things about Michael B
Jordan as the character kill monger as
the villain and he is great when he
shows up when he's on screen his
motivation is clear you understand to a
degree where he's coming from but of
course he's a villain so he's going
about it the wrong way
those make for the best villains of my
book but again I say when he shows up
because for the first half of this movie
he doesn't I found that to be a problem
he does one thing near the beginning of
the movie then after that I forgot he
was in it and he finally shows up and
starts doing his thing and it kind of
gave this movie the feeling of being
black panther and black panther -
crushed into one
movie which I don't know if that was the
case I don't know if they were like that
we have two ideas for Black Panther
we'll make him one I don't know if they
were like we have an idea for Black
Panther but hey we got it incorporate
Klaw into the movie or if they were like
we're going for the Godfather feeling
where it's like three movies in one
well Godfather was three movies in
Willing this feels like - I don't know
all I know is it makes Black Panther
feel like it was split down the middle
into two movies and it feels like a
season of 24 if you remember the show 24
it had 24 episodes of season but it was
really two arcs twelve episodes each
episode twelve rolled into episode
thirteen and the new arc just like this
movie does but it does feel like two
different seasons just like Black
Panther feels like two different movies
but in the end Black Panther was
fantastic it has your fun superhero
stuff in it yeah but that's not what the
movie is it's not what it's about it
really is about a king coming into the
throne and dealing with being a new king
and while they're telling that story
they bring you in on a very interesting
fascinating colorful and vibrant
civilization I feel like most people who
go into Black Panther will enjoy Black
Panther it's all about how much you
enjoy black panther are you going to
like it or love it I don't know this up
to you but it's worth paying money for
it's worth watching and worth buying on
blu-ray that's right that is a purple
blue right because when this movie comes
out on blu-ray if the blue part of the
blu-ray package isn't purple that's a
missed opportunity marketing people a
lot of purple and black in this movie
personal favorite color scheme of mine
or it's a black panther it is here it is
upon us have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you